bonjour et des rdt bonjour grégoire
bonjour khadijetou bonjour vous êtes à
l'accueil de jour de pithiviers ici
l'association humanis affiliés à la
fondation abbé pierre offre un refuge
aux plus démunis les gens qui viennent
ici et qui ont besoin parfois dead
administratives et après au niveau des
services le petit déjeuner la lingerie
cette année avec l'arrivée de l'hiver la
structure assure une continuité de
l'accueil en ouvrant toute la journée un
lieu ressource important pour les sans
abri un cas qui nous poursuivre pour les
démarches et tout ça on n'est pas tout
seul et non son entourage pour justement
pour démarrer la nouveauté de l'accueil
d'urgence cette année à pithiviers c'est
la création d'un samu social avec l'aide
de la préfecture du loiret il ya des
gens qu'il faut aller chercher parce que
le parcours fait que parfois ils sont un
peu méfiant réticents en retrait de tous
les dispositifs classiques l'accueil
qu'on propose à l'accueil de jour c'est
pas le même accueil que vous allez avoir
dans des bureaux d'institutions franchir
la porte de la maison du département
c'est pas les mêmes conditions qu ici
ici l'accueil il est inconditionnel vous
voulez pas nous donner votre nom votre
prénom
on vous accueillera quand même vous
bénéficierez quand même des services
vous pourrez quand même prendre un petit
déjeuner une douche chaude faire laver
votre linge
voilà donc le but c'est aussi ces gens
là de leur permettre d'améliorer un peu
leur quotidien à pithiviers comme
ailleurs personne ne doit rester à la
rue cet hiver